many families are finally making travel
plans again with covid mostly on the
decline spring break
vacations almost said vaccinations
spring break locations are rebounding up
more than 130 percent 130 percent from a
year ago think about that jamie yuka is
headed to a nickelodeon themed resort in
mexico a partnership with our parent
company that would be paramount global
where families are making up for a lost
time
[Music]
for many spring break means sunny skies
and sandy beaches
after two years of avoiding crowds
andrews fan cook and his family were
ready to start traveling again we
haven't been able to do those types of
things for so long so what does that
feel like normal
back to normal
yeah it feels exciting again
[Applause]
they chose the new nickelodeon themed
resort in riviera maya mexico for their
first getaway
an upgrade from the makeshift ride the
family made in their backyard while
hunkered down in houston in 2020. it
feels awesome
being able to get her experiences again
be able to get out and about so you get
to be a kid again
definitely that's the whole purpose of
the trip to be a kid again and enjoy
life a recent travel report found that
almost 80 percent of those surveyed are
most looking forward to traveling with
their family in 2022
but making memories as a family is more
than just a good time it's good for your
health you look at all the data they're
more productive they have you know more
calmness less anxiety and they have
better relations with others and so to
have these experiences are what really
bonds you long term families that are
successful are families that take those
adventures
this sprawling beachfront property was
designed for togetherness rooms can
accommodate two adults and three kids or
more it is really difficult to design a
space that is good for multiple
generations we call it multi-gen travel
a travel business strategist sandra
mclemore says families are making up for
lost time they've been home for two
years so maybe where they might have
taken two or three days they're now
traveling for a little bit longer but in
true nickelodeon style if you want to
have fun just add slime
some 40 years ago it was slime that
helped launch the brand to stardom as a
90s kid i loved watching green goo rain
down on celebrities there's something
i've wanted to do since i was probably 9
or 10 years old and i'm about to go do
it
i wasn't the only one are you ready to
get slimed
anthony and rikita starks experience the
slime of a lifetime with their kids
it was super duper great
[Applause]
i loved it it felt
amazing what was so great about it
because it was something i grew up
seeing and it's finally
happened to me was this more about the
two of you than it was
[Laughter]
after two years of juggling careers kids
and school at home the starks were eager
for their first family adventure how
important is it for families to make
these kind of memories together
it's very important without them it's
just
life is doyle you don't want to just
exist you want to live so this is living
give us an experience to come down the
slides lester adams is part of the team
overseeing location-based experiences
for paramount global which owns
nickelodeon and cbs news it seems like
you almost have a perfect situation in
terms of covid where families can come
and be outside almost the entire time it
really gives you this the space to
stretch out and be outside and enjoy the
fresh air in a way that a lot of people
in a lot of places weren't able to do
during cover
[Laughter]
as lockdowns are lifted some familiar
and perhaps surprising
spring break sounds are returning
and so are those opportunities to bond
with friends and family what will you
remember the most about this trip
spending time with family
oh that's so nice for cbs mornings i'm
jamie yukas in riviera maya mexico
i i like young mr starks who said that's
super duper great oh yeah i think it's
perfect when you've got kids urinated
because when you've got kids your age
you want to go to places like that when
they're potty trained and employed
you're like where's the adult pool
i think this is so fun for family oh
it's super fun and i'm glad that mom and
dad admitted that the nickelodeon
sliming theme was more about them than
the kids that was a great memory for
everybody